hey everyone divolo here and in today's
video we are starting another series
which in the next two videos i will be
going over the final arc of probably one
of the greatest stories in manga of all
time the ride that everyone has been on
over the last almost 10 years with the
anime and even longer with the manga has
been completely outstanding with every
releasing season since the first
exploding in popularity and doing even
greater than its last has had the effect
of becoming somewhat iconic throughout
the anime and manga community as
something that each studio or mangaka
should strive to achieve so without
holding back any more let's get into the
end of this amazing series and part one
of the one and only war for parodies arc
of attack on titan but just before you
do if you are interested and explain
videos like this for a multitude of
series then make sure you hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video as it really
helps out with pushing my stuff to a
bunch of new amazing people but anyway
enough of that let's get into the final
arc of attack on titan
inside of the prison where the survey
corps and other military prisons are
kept their walls begin to rattle as
above hundreds of mali and soldiers
parachute down from the airships pete
calls out to gallia to break the chain
holding her to gabby in which he
complies by severing peak's wrist from
your arm before turning his attention
back to erin pig throws herself off the
roof to give herself the room she needs
to transform then carries gabby away
inside of the mouth of the cart titan
while the battle rages on behind her
aaron is caught off guard by the bali
and surprise attack and yelena yells for
him to leave his titan so that he can
hide indoors however realizing that this
attack has to be the work of rainer he
ignores yelena and jumps over the side
of the building to walk out into the
streets of the town at the same time
reina parachutes down from above with
his hand bleeding and transforms he
lands then faces off with aaron and the
two begin brawling spotty mcgath pig
brings gabby over to him where cole also
is and he immediately asks gabby about
his brother falco gabby informs him that
falco had accidentally drunk zeke's
spinal fluid and is currently locked up
and peak provides additional information
regarding the number of detained
audience soldiers who also drank the
spinal fluid she also says that she
suspects that aaron cannot currently use
the founding titan's power without zeke
otherwise he would have already used it
this causes gabby to remember the
conversation between zeke and aaron how
they now had the founding titan and a
titan of royal blood making them realise
that z could possibly be of royal blood
which is also affirmed by zeke's unique
powers with the beast titan they state
they cannot let zeke and aaron come into
contact aaron and reina continue
fighting with galiyad attacking aaron
from behind which lets reina grab a hold
of him from the front aaron though uses
the power of the warhammer titan to
impale them both and the jaegerists move
in with their thunder spears to finish
off the armored and jaw titans but
before they can even fire a large shell
passes the head of aaron's titan mcgath
atop the wall calls out for another shot
to be loaded into the artillery cannon
on pig's back while this happens the
malian military provides cover fire in
the form of soldiers on the ground and
guns in the airships above magath fires
another shallow errand forcing him to
keep using his power knowing that the
warhammer's stamina can be quickly
exhausted this gives runner a chance to
get in close and galio lunges at eren
when aaron hurls him away rana finally
gets in and pins aaron down and prepares
to buy open his nape however aaron
screams and refuses to give up he
wrenches the armored titan's head away
from its shore causing reiner to fall
back as a large boulder also shatters
against his titan's body thrown by no
one other than the big monkey zeke he
tells erin that he did a great job but
now it's time to leave the race to him
zeke hurls a barrage of boulders
striking various malerian ships causing
them to crash he then proceeds to throw
several projectiles towards peak causing
him to dive over the side of the wall
she advises against fighting the beast
titan right now but mcgath refuses
declaring that he will personally pass
judgement on zeke for his betrayal
galliad lays among the ruins of several
buildings noting that the blow was more
severe than he'd anticipated nearby
rainer also lays defeated within the
mangled remains of his tyson and aaron
continues his approach witnessing this
colt orders gabby to retreat but gabby
refuses still wanting to help falco as
the imprisoned members of the military
demand to be released niall sits with
falco and proposes that it's a rescue
attempt to free him but falco bitterly
states that mali would never do that for
a mere aldian niall mentions though that
falco had a chance to return home to his
family while the others likely will not
and will soon be turned into titans
elsewhere maiji onyen kopon releases the
locked up survey corps members and begs
them to help aaron when connie refuses
to help armin convinces him and he also
agrees that onion kopon had no part in
yelana and zeke's plot onion coupon
suggests that they help aaron and zeke
without whom paradise would be in danger
from all of the world's armies mikasa
weakly agrees on helping aaron but armin
responds by saying that he believes eren
lied and the euthanasia plan sounded
nothing like him when connie questions
why aaron sided with zeke and elena
arman replies that he had to in order to
protect the island by awakening the
hundreds of titans inside shiganishina's
walls and annihilating the world's major
military forces no other force would
ever dare attack parodies for years
gene admits to being envious of eren in
the past but refuses to see him die just
yet connie agrees to help as well and
they set out to rescue the other
prisoners after taking out the jagaris
guards connie finds shadis lying wounded
on a beard claiming to have fought a
beer he insists that connie forget about
him and leave meanwhile pexus commands
the soldiers without the black armbands
to gear up within maneuvering gear and
those who drug the wine would fight the
enemies from the front lines louise
tells mikasa that she is glad that they
are working towards the same goal and
that she can fight by her side again
makers of the unfolds her scarf leaving
it behind falco and nile spot colt and
gabby nearby nell brings him over and
their three flee before joining his
comrades as they take refuge inside a
nearby home gabby goes over the numerous
acts of kindness and charity she had
witnessed on parodies and finally
understands the dramatic change in
rainer's behaviour the aldians on
parodies indeed are no different from
those in mali falco then admits his
unwitting role in the raid and knowing
he will likely be turned into a titan he
admits why he became a warrior candidate
but cult proposes that zeke may stop
from transforming everyone if he is
aware falco was among those who consumed
the wine the survey could face
resistance from both sides and galiot
attempts to rush aaron only to get
petaled by more stones from zeke
observing the charred remains of the
cart titan physique silently laments
that pique was killed in such a manner
at the same time as the yeagers cheer
their success several members are
suddenly shot by mali and snipers zeke
notices the gun barrel of the titan
artillery cannon on peak as directly
facing him as peak says mcgath fires
blowing a hole through the right
shoulder of the beast titan severely
injuring zeke as zeke falls mcgath
becomes annoyed that he does not have
another clear shot and fears that zeke
may still let out his scream as members
of the malian army continue attacking
rhino recovers and spots aaron
approaching zeke gilead lunges and halts
the attack titan by biting into his leg
seeing this aaron then ruthlessly beats
down on the jaw titan striking his nape
and critically wounding galliad aaron is
then shot once more by mcgarth but
before he can fire again the eggarists
come from behind and strike at the cart
titan arm and mikasa are pinned down by
gunfire from several soldiers bocconi
launches a thunderspear and orders that
they take out the malian soldiers before
going after the kart titan inside the
nape of the beast titan zeke's entire
back has been completely destroyed from
the rounds fired from the car titan he
notices that he is now on the ground and
begins to get to his feet as reiner and
aaron continue fighting each other
runner grabs galiot in an attempt to
wake him up but unexpectedly transfers
the memory of marcel to him revealing
that he tried to protect gilead from
becoming a warrior this raises him out
of his slump and he becomes emotional
and unable to speak as zeke is about to
summon the titans colt arrives and plays
with him to let falco run clear so that
he will not be affected while stunned
that falco had consumed some of his
spinal fluid zeke still ends up letting
out a bone-shattering scream
transforming everyone along with falco
commander pixies and nile throughout the
entire shigen shina district into
mindless titans the titans instantly
turn towards the numerous malians and
easily kill them rina notices a
transform falco charging towards him on
the orders from zeke and begins trying
to fight him again z gets shot but this
time armin and mikasa take the car titan
by surprise killing the soldiers
accompanying it at the same time seeing
zeke's immobile body runner began to
remove his armor so that falco could
bite through but before falco could do
so he spots the wounded galliad limping
towards him and rhino as he thinks about
marcel's sacrifice galiot allows himself
to be consumed by falco transferring the
jaw titan to him runner strikes eren in
blind frustration but aaron instantly
hardens his body encasing him while he
runs towards zeke runner tries to crush
aaron but is shot in the hand by a
thundersphere causing it to explode as
aaron and zeke finally get closer erin
notices out of the corner of his eye
that a tearful witch has picked up a
rifle instantly she shoots right into
and through aaron's neck decapitating
him and sending his head spiraling as
zeke screams in horror aaron's
decapitated head lands in the
outstretched hand of zeke causing aaron
to wake up in the desert realm
accessible via the paths he says a
pillar of light that branches out below
he meets an aged physique who sits
chained on the sandy ground zeke informs
erin that it is the coordinate where all
paths converge he believes that this is
the realm where members of the royal
family came whenever they used the
founding titan though gabby succeeded in
blowing aaron's head off zeke was still
able to make contact with him in the
real world before erin's life had ended
allowing them to succeed in gaining the
founder's true power a girl in a ragged
dress approaches them with zeke calling
her yamir the founder he believes she
created all the titans here before they
ascend to the physical world when aaron
inquires about the chains zeke is
shackled to zeke explains that they
represent the vow of renouncing war
hence why aaron is the only one who can
currently walk freely and command the
founder zeke pleads with aaron to go
ahead and start the euthanization plan
however aaron refuses revealing that he
had only pretended to go along with
zeke's plan so that he could end up here
in the coordinates severely disheartened
zeke asks erin why and aaron replies
it's because i was born into this world
aaron asks samia to lend him her
strength but she ignores him and kneels
before zeke zeke laments erin's
mentality and brainwashing by their
father removing the chains around his
body he explains that he learnt many
things while waiting for aaron to wake
up and that he can create anything in
this land as long as he with his royal
blood wills it unlike the past members
zeke entered the coordinate without
being tainted by carl fritz's ideology
he says though yamir is powerful but in
actuality she simply submits to anyone
with royal blood while they are there
zeke has the power of the founder and
aaron was simply a key chains appear
around aaron as zeke explains that he is
glad to hear how his younger brother
truly feels zeke doesn't blame him
though as here tom is a surrogate father
he believes that aaron needs someone to
rescue him as well and thus zeke plans
to use the power of the founder to fix
aaron he does so by forcing the two of
them into gracious memories where they
see grisha and carla playing with the
newborn aaron zeke plans to show aaron
how his father had sown the seeds of the
nationalism into him until the latter
understands watching gracious spend time
with his family zeke is clearly
dissatisfied with how grecia enjoyed his
life with his new family as if his old
one had never even existed zeke shows
aaron how his father used his position
as a doctor to treat him minister and
get close to those in power even though
things would go horribly for his family
if he was ever caught he still went
ahead he even found the basement beneath
the chapel where the race family would
hold their rituals however this was
years before the day where maria got
breached gracia ultimately went back to
his family with zeke conceding that he
really did seem to love them enough that
he set aside his mission to retake the
founder he thinks that perhaps grisha
had learned from his past as he loved
his second son almost to the point of
ending everything as a restorationist
however zeke brushes aside that now
because aaron is doing exactly as grecia
would have wanted him to he tells erin
that he is not his true self anymore and
he will soon understand why the two of
them stand in the jaeger family basement
and talk nearly sleeping grisha when
their father mutters apologizing to zeke
he looked up in the direction we see
stood by a cabinet and both erin and
zeke are surprised that grisha and his
memories seem to be able to see zeke
asking if he was there confused gracias
sat back down and dismissed the vision
as a dream because he could not imagine
how a bearded old man could be his son
zeke stands in disbelief as aaron
reaches the door of the basement
prompting zeke to move forward still
inside the memories zeke is surprised
that aaron was raised without the same
indoctrination he received given aaron's
freedom to choose zeke is puzzled that
aaron would betray him and carry out his
father's plans after he received the
attack titan aaron though reveals that
he had always been this way the two of
them then arrived at a memory where
aaron killed two robbers who had
kidnapped mikasa with zeke being just as
surprised as grecia gracias scolds aaron
while the present-day aaron explains
that zeke expected the two of them to be
similarly scarred but aaron fights
because that is who he is and not what
his father made him he is different from
zeke who aaron sees as a man who can
only define himself by his willingness
to deny his father who died years ago
zeke chooses to express gratitude
instead because grisha was the one who
opened his eyes to the danger of aldia
as they go through more memories zeke
refuses to give up on saving aaron the
two of them watch the yeager family as
the childhood aaron expresses his desire
to join the survey corps the young aaron
talks about not wanting to be ignorant
of the world outside the walls and wants
to carry on the work of those who
sacrifice their lives grisha then offers
to show aaron his secret in the basement
after he gets home but when grisha
leaves he becomes bothered seeing a
vision of the evacuation of shiganoshina
because of this he returned to the
chapel where he had previously
discovered the stairs leading
underground he follows them down and
finds the members of the race family
gathered in the cavern below grisha
explains that he is an aldian at a
subject of ymir who has come from beyond
the walls he asks the king of the walls
to kill all of the titans attacking the
wall before his family and the other
people within the walls could be easily
eaten freyda is initially distressed by
his words but then her expression
smooths as the will of the first king
takes over she refuses to help grecia
calling this a time of judgment the rest
of mankind is too weak in the face of
the power of the titans so in order to
protect the world the eldean people must
accept their sins and perish still
watching zeke is aware that the race
family will soon be slaughtered and asks
erin if that was all a lie but aaron
doesn't reply instead he stares intently
at grecia who is becoming increasingly
worried gresha wants to know how this
can be atonement when the people are
ignorant of their history and had no
part in what happened frederick agrees
that this is not atonement because they
can never replace the lives that they
took but they can prevent the taking of
future lives outside of the walls as
long as aldians remain ignorant they
will be the only ones to die since he's
something beyond him rishi just barely
turns to see erin glaring ominously at
the race family even zeke notices that
something is odd frederick continues her
speech though and informs grecia that
even if he were to take the founding
titan from her he would be unable to use
it but grisha admits that he knows this
and shares with her that they attack
titan has its own unique power it is
able to see into the memories of its
future inheritors and through them it
can know the future freight is not aware
of this because of the vow to renounce
war that prevents her from being able to
use the full power of the founder grisha
tells freida that he will take the
founding titan from her and in the royal
bloodline setting the future that he
already knows is going to happen but his
hand shakes as he grips his scalpel to
injure himself it falls from his hands
and clatters to the cavern floor and
gracious sobs that they cannot kill
children as he has a doctor who was
supposed to save lives zeke is puzzled
because he is aware that the race family
died and there is not any way that the
past could have changed the race family
began to rally from their hiding places
shouting for frida to kill grisha and
protect them as aaron walks up to his
father still glaring he demands that
gracias stand and asks if he forgot why
he had come here in the first place erin
brings up all the things that grisha had
set aside over the years revenge for
faye dina the aldian restorationists
krueger he demands that they need to
keep moving forward to avenge them even
if they die and even after they die he
repeats what krueger had previously
asked griesha that he was the one who
started this this convinces grisha to
take up his scalpel and stab it through
his hand he then decimates the entire
race family with only rod escaping
fresher leaves the chapel taking a
syringe of spinal fluid with him he
collapses telling aaron that he killed
the rey's family and asks if he is happy
now if this is what he wanted rishi
wants to know if this was what he truly
had to do in order to save aldia but
aaron does not reply gracious sobs
asking why erin did not show him
everything he saw the walls being
destroyed but not where the khala is
safe after a moment he asks if zeke is
there and tells him that everything now
will go aaron's way instead of zeke's he
looks up and truly sees zeke this time
he stands up and apologizes for being a
terrible father despite zeke's
apprehension grisha embraces him he
tells zeke that he loves him and he
wishes he spent more time playing with
him overcome zeke calls him dead and
grisha warns him that he has to stop
aaron the connection between the two
brothers breaks and they find themselves
back in the realms of their paths zeke
realizes now that aaron is the one who
pushed grisha to kill the royal family
and by extension fight the rest of the
world but considering that the attack
tightened kentron's same time he's
surprised that aaron also showed grisha
events that were unfavorable to him zeke
concludes that grisha was willing to
steal the founding titan even though he
could not use it because of a different
memory aaron has shown him eren thanks
zeke for making his plan possible by
bringing him into grisha's memories and
says that that time with astoria he had
seen a side of brush's memories and
within them he saw his then future self
and the sights of things to come zeke
panics and shouts for yamir to steal the
ability to reproduce from all subjects
of ymir causing the girl to turn away
and walk towards the coordinate he tells
aaron that he does not know what kind of
future he saw in grisha's memories but
he did not see everything just as he did
not know that he would be unable to use
the power of the founder here aaron's
wrists are still shackled but he frees
himself by literally tearing so hard
that he rips off some fingers as he
chases after yamir zeke tells him that
it is pointless and that nothing in this
world can stop her in the past freida
told her sister historia that she should
be like the girl in her storybook
because she is kind and always thinking
of others however that girl had lived in
a harsh time when her people were
enslaved by the aldian tribe when one of
those slaves let a pig escape fritz the
tribal leader calls for his slaves to
identify the culprit or he will gouge
out an eye from every one of them the
other slaves immediately point to a
single girl yamir who was surprised but
bows her head and takes the blame as a
result she is set loose and chased by
hunters on horseback with dogs blood
runs from one of her eyes and she is hit
a few times by arrows but she still runs
until she finds a gigantic tree with a
cave opening at the base of its trunk
yamin walks inside and stumbles head
first into the depths a spine-like
creature floats beneath her linking up
with her vertebrae and begins to morph
with her as she drifts down
suddenly the forest erupts and the tree
falls as ymir emerges as the founding
titan
fritz leader of aldia keeps yamir as a
slave though and puts her to work and by
the time that she is an adult she had
built roads cultivated the land and made
bridges between mountains fritz decided
that she would also bear his children
but sends her to destroy the people of
mali which she does with complete ease
the time then passes and yamir had three
children for fritz when malian officers
kneel before fritz one of them rises in
retaliation and heaves to spare at him
however yamir intervenes by jumping in
front of the spear which impales her
through her shoulder she collapses in
front of fritz who is surprised but asks
what she is doing since they spear
should not kill her he commands her to
rise calling her his slave once more but
nothing happens fritz cuts up yamir's
body and has their daughters maria rose
and sheena eat it he commands his
daughters to bear children and multiply
so that yamir's blood does not die out
when they die they do the same with
their own children so their power is
forever passed down and the aldians will
rule the land through the use of their
massive titans in the present eren grabs
a hold of ymir while inside the paths
and tells her that it all ends now he
asks her to lend him her strength so
that he can put an end to this world and
tells her that she is a person and not a
slave and that she has the right to
choose rather than to serve seeing this
zeke panics and yells his command a
second time for yamir to sterilize all
subjects and reminds her that he is the
one of royal blood but before he can
reach them erin cradles you mere close
and asks if she was the one that led him
here as she must have been waiting for
two thousand years for someone to come
tears in her eyes appear as ymir lifts
her head back in the battle a spiny
substance connects aaron's decapitated
head to the body as the battle rages on
walmart begins to crap and shatter it
crumbles revealing the wall titans
inside and the skeleton of another titan
which rises up in front of a horrified
gabby mikusa remembers when she and the
others went abroad for the first time
though everyone has said that erin has
changed she wonders if that was true or
if he had actually been the same person
the entire time when their survey corps
arrived in mali they were disguised to
blend in with the local population but
they are astonished to see towns and
people beyond the walls onion coupon
greeted and offered to guide them to
kyomi's estates connie sasha and hans
are shocked to see a car for the first
time and acted if it was some kind of
animal while this happened mikasa found
erin staring off into the distance
almond tried to get aaron to liven up by
reminding him that they are finally in
the outside world but aaron who had
already seen most things through his
father's memories wasn't too excited
because he wonders if anybody had
realized that erin had changed or if
they'd just not want to notice the
changes as they take in the sights levi
catches a young boy where they fears
lifting sasha's purse and tells the kid
that it does not belong to him loud
enough that the others overhear the
malian crowd takes it poorly as the boy
is an immigrant who does not speak their
language as the malians assume that he
must have snuck abroad a ship and
discuss making an example of him to
discourage others sashi tries to
intervene but the malians are still
hostile and insinuate that the boy could
be a subject of ymir seeing the boys
fear levi scoops him under one arm and
clarifies that he never said the child
was a pickpocketer and that the purse is
his older sisters nobody buys the excuse
though but levi and the other soldiers
end up running off with the boy though
happy to be free the boy thanks levi by
stealing his wallet before leaving
at kiyomi's estate she listens to the
story of what happened to them along the
way and confirms that blood testing has
improved and as a result of that
subjects of yamir who have escaped the
internments are constantly being
discovered being a subject of ymir used
to be a proof of one's status in society
but when the aldian empire crumbled
those same people were chased out of
their own countries because of this
kyomi states that it would be difficult
for them to form friendly relationships
with other nations
ahmed is still hopeful though so they
avoid implementing zeke's plan and
historia will not have to bear children
to serve as royal blooded titans mikasa
notices that aaron has left their
meeting with kiyomi and goes outside to
look for him she finds him looking at a
cluster of refugee tents at first she
begins to rebuke him for going outside
alone but then she realizes that he is
looking at the boy who stole from them
as well as that boy's family erin tells
her that these tents are where people
live after losing their homes to war the
people here are like the two of them one
day life just stopped being normal and
everything was taken away he asks mikasa
why she cares about him so much whether
it is because he saved her when they
were kids or because they are family
mechuses stammers and begins to say that
he is family when the boy's father walks
up to them disappointed at the timing
aaron instead gestures that they should
all join him and their refugees they
enjoy a meal together and after the two
groups warm up it turns into a party
gene and connie ran out to bring more
alcohol and their refugees join the
group mikasa and ahman have a good time
while erin smiles later the forum for
the association to protect the subjects
of ymir goes poorly a speaker defends
only the subjects of ymir who are not
aldian and tells everyone to reserve
their hatred for the devils of parody's
island mikasa realizes that that was the
day that aaron had left their side later
they received a letter from him saying
that he would entrust everything to zeke
she wonders if their current situation
could have been avoided if she chose a
different answer to erin that first time
he had asked her what she was to him in
the present mikasa and amun are
surrounded by the ruins of shiganushina
after their walls have crumbled and
their wall titans have broken free in
their distance she sees a massive
skeleton that dwarfs even their newly
free titans and notices that it seems to
have appeared where eren was beside her
armon shouts to make herself heard over
the rumbling and tells mikasa that aaron
must have taken control of the founding
titan he believes that aaron will use it
to stop mali's invasion but as armin
looks around he realizes that it is not
just the wall surrounding shiganoshima
that has been destroyed but the arrest
of war maria which is unnecessary if all
aaron intends to do is to repel the
current attack aaron then reaches out
all of the subjects of ymir using the
founding titan's power and his voice
reverberates in their minds and he
explains that he has unhardened all of
the walls friendly titans within them he
intends to protect the people of
parodies however the rest of the world
desires their extinction so he intends
to trample their lands beyond the island
until all life beyond parodies has been
completely and utterly destroyed in
liberio annie's father sags to his knees
in the marketplace in reaction to eren's
declaration that he would be sending
titans to destroy everyone else in the
world back on paradise gabby leads rhina
on a search for falco rana believes that
falco was kidnapped following his
emergence from his titan since jean and
connie would not want to leave someone
as valuable as him behind weakened by
having the armor of his titan stripped
off by aaron's removal of the walls
reiner collapses and laments that he was
unable to stop aaron from destroying the
world gabby helps him into an empty
building and reina tries to get her to
flee to the malian airships but she asks
him what good it would do all the people
in their family are going to die so they
would have to kill aaron to stop this
reiner does not believe this is possible
though but after he passes out gabby
covers him with a blanket and leaves
food in arm's reach before deciding that
she will rescue falco on her own on top
of a rooftop mikasa armin jean and
connie surround a captive and
unconscious falco gene expresses
disbelief that aaron has chosen to
slaughter the rest of the world but
acknowledges that the hatred against the
island would disappear with their deaths
the one thing the outside world feared
the most has happened because they tried
to kill the people of parodies disturbed
by this line of thinking gene asks for
confirmation that there was truly
nothing else that could have been done
aaron has rejected zeke's euthanization
plan and rejected sacrifice in historia
so he must be doing all of this to
protect his friends who he has said mean
more to him than anything in the entire
world the four are broken out of their
lull but the sight of the aldean
soldiers fights him with the newly
formed titans armin is surprised since
aaron should be able to control them if
he has command over the founder before
they can head into help mekis asks gene
what he intends to do with falco and
jean suggests that they intend to feed
him to a titan to save someone since
falco had just inherited the jaw titan
and connie interrupts to say that they
will fade him to his mother ahman argues
against this though since it will start
a new conflict between them and the
warrior yoona but connie refuses to
listen when an approaching titan
distracts the group connie escapes with
falco leaving the rest to deal with the
titans at before yelena wonders why zika
is not in control of the approaching
titans and these streets are the city
the blaus family and nicolo free from
one of the newly created titans with
kaya accidentally falling down a set of
stairs the titan pursues her giving her
flashbacks to when her mother was being
devoured right in front of her
frightened she asks for a sister to save
her but as the titan lunges for her it
is shot through their mouth by gabby
causing it to fall she then jumps in
front of kaya and jams her rifle into
the titan's throat so that she can blow
out its nape gabby explains to nikolo
that she came back to rescue falco when
an aldian soldier sees them and demands
to know if gabby was the one who had
killed that titan and if she was the
killed from ali kaia covers for gabi
telling him that she is part of their
family as the aldian soldier leads them
to safety gabby asks kaya why she
covered for her kai doesn't answer
instead asking why gabby saved her when
kai is supposed to be a devil gabby
tries to correct her saying that herself
is the real devil she had killed a lot
of people just to earn praise nikola
tells the girls that there is a devil
inside all of them and that is why the
world has turned out this way back at
the fort zerma is nearly eaten by tyson
when he is saved by shadis who berates
the soldier for not remembering the
training he had given him he orders them
to put on some equipment and follow him
mikasa gene and armin reach the fort and
begin fighting the titans around it gene
orders everyone to move to the top floor
to concentrate the titans in one place
and destroy them with the thunder spears
once prepared he has them all fire at
once wiping out the titans the shigeru
sheena district is completely in
shambles and surrounded by massive
titans but the battle itself appears to
be done nearly all the malian soldiers
have been wiped out and the smaller
titans are gone onion coupon asks jane
what eren it tends to do and chin says
exactly what it looks like causing him
to realize that this likely means his
homeland is doomed flock returns having
survived the walls coming down and tries
to put up a cheerful front gene despite
gene's distaste for him he says that he
cannot die and the moment of the
audience empire's return and walks up to
elena who was sitting dispirited in a
cheer flot points a pistol at her and
says to go gather the volunteers as they
are going to be restrained much to gene
and onion coupon's surprise inside of
the fort armand and mikasa are
pleasantly surprised to see that sasha's
father is alright and even more
surprised to see that gabby has returned
gabby tells them that she no longer
wants to fight them she just wants to
save falco and then she will leave
however almond explains how connie has
taken falco to save his mother gabby
becomes saddened by the news but she
decides to try and figure out a way to
fix connie's mum she thinks if ahman
asks aaron he'll change her back for him
as the founding titan should be able to
do so aman was surprised to hear this
and pressed gabby to tell him what she
knew and when she tells him that it was
when the walls fell and ahman remembers
that aaron said he would undo all of the
hardening in an underground room the
crystal surrounding annie has shattered
she coughs and wakes up finding herself
lying on the floor in the stohis
district hitch and the other members of
their military police dig out survivors
from the rubble left by the walking
titans the titans are not hostiles the
island humans but the human population
is still split over aaron's actions and
waking them some blame aaron for the
deaths caused by the crumbling walls and
others defend them as an acceptable
sacrifice seeing the civilians begin to
clash one of the mps tells hitch to
return to the headquarters and bring
back recruits and weapons while she
organizes that effort she notices a
trail of liquid coming from the basement
and then ending at a closet door hitch
opens the door and is immediately
assaulted by annie who threatens to cut
open her neck using her ring however
hitch is able to break free and throws
annie over her shoulder hitch panics
trying to think of a way to restrain any
before she transforms only to realise
that annie's already injured herself and
can turn into the female titan at any
time and he uses this to threaten hitch
into obeying her but hitch calls her
bluff claiming that annie is too weak to
do that right now someone then knocks on
the door asking if he's okay while she
makes up her mind a short time later
hitch and annie are in these stables and
hitch says that this is for the best
because she will no longer have to watch
over annie's body and any response that
in that case she won't have to listen to
hitch talk about men either surprised
hatch realizes that annie would have
been conscious for the entire four years
she has been inside of the crystal and
he describes it being like a dream in
which she would hear both hitch and
armin as if they were far away she had
then found herself thrown out of her
slumber as she had heard aaron's voice
and he asks hitch if he was serious
about destroying the world with the
rumbling and what she says that he is
and as they ride out she tells annie to
look at the titans she feels that the
only worthwhile job she has done as a
soldier has been to clean up the corpses
and rubble in the aftermath of both
annie and erin hatch asks annie how she
feels seeing all of their bodies
trampled for the sake of her plan and
annie says that she had a lot of time to
think about it while she was inside of
her crystal and she realizes how little
the warrior unit thought at all they
were praised for killing anyone outside
of mali's borders but even though the
warriors were supposed to stop the
rumbling and he tells hitch that she
never cared about saving the outside
world annie was abandoned shortly after
birth due to blood tests they showed her
mother having an affair with an aldian
and she was adopted by an aldian man
from another country he trained him
mercilessly to become a warrior in order
to improve his own lots and life and she
paid him back by making sure he could
never walk properly again despite that
he was happy because it meant she could
kill her enemies even unarmed because of
her training everything stopped
mattering to annie even her own life
until the moment the warriors were to
head to the parody's island to retake
the founding titan that was when her
father apologized to her and said that
everything he taught her had been wrong
none of what she had earned her status
as being a warrior or an honorary malian
citizen mattered as long as she came
back to him and he tells hitch that her
father is waiting for her and others
have people just as important to them
too she knows she has committed
irredeemable sins but thinks that she
would still do them if it meant
returning to her father hit appreciates
annie's openness with her but is afraid
at that point as if annie gets back all
she will find will be rubble and corpses
meanwhile in liberio the aldians in the
internment zone bunch up around the
authorities at the gate and his father
is at the head and tries to explain to
the security officers that aaron is
coming and has activated the rumbling
however the officers are too skeptical
and accuse the audience of conspiring to
escape they begin to arrest the aldian's
presence but mr leonhart thinks of his
daughter and her promise to return which
drives him to fight back back in
shiganshina shadus and a few of the
other trainees overhear gunfire from the
jaegerists who have gathered to take
over the ford swerma suggests that they
run but keith argues against it since
the people support the jaegerists the
jagaris will soon take over the island
and there will no longer be a safe place
for people like him he tells the
trainees to side with the jaegers to
keep themselves safe and then rise up
when the opportunity comes elsewhere
armin prepares to chase after connie
even if it might not work out he feels
obligated to do everything he can in
order to win gabby's trust reiner and
the kart titan are still somewhere in
the area and having gabby on their side
could make a big difference in whether
the two groups could ever work together
amin is weary and would rather not be
doing this but if he doesn't it could
have a huge effect on humanity's future
mikasa asks him what she should do and
ama tells her to help jean and to think
of herself for once when she asks him
about aaron almond blows up in
frustration over their collective
helplessness and how many people are
still in danger painfully overwhelmed he
tells mikasa that they are no longer in
a place to think about eren as he is a
lost cause makusa apologizes varmin
catches himself and laments that he was
the one who was saved instead of erwin
as erwin would have not snapped like
that later on make us the notes that the
scarf she had previously set aside is
now gone at the top of the fort flock
shoots one of the anti-malian volunteers
in the hand to enforce the new position
with the jaegerists he explains that
aaron told him his plan to manipulate
zeke 10 months ago and flock rounded up
comrades to help aaron's cause thot
tells the volunteers that protecting
their island is now a lost cause but
they will be welcomed as aldians if they
choose to fight for the sake of the
island when the volunteer here
previously maimed objects flock shoots
him in the head even as he praises them
for refusing to submit in the face of a
bullet however phlox says that pride is
not worth dying for he gives orders for
the volunteers to be taken to their
cells for they will have time to think
because it comes up the stairs to see
their volunteers being led away and asks
what happened vlog summarizes his stance
that he sees his own role as wiping out
any resentment that remains inside of
the island he tells mikasa and a shell
shock gene that this is freedom and that
they do not have to fight any longer
flock reminds gene of his dream to
become an np telling him that he can now
do that but insults jane's former
attitude after gene asks if their fight
is over mikasa asks what happened to
hanj and levi with fox saying that they
were killed by zeke out in the
wilderness connie is riding with falco
under the presence that he is taking
falco to safety so he can get his
amnesia treated falco was grateful since
he has a gap in his memory of what
happened after meeting up with gabby and
his older brother colt however he cannot
shake the feeling that he has met connie
somewhere before also in the wilderness
pekin mcgrath watched the malaria
airships retreat team magath thinks this
is a smart move since they can warn the
rest of the world about what has
happened but pique is feeling down since
there's no way to get the titan wall to
even stop hanj calls out to the two of
them and pique still partially inside of
her titan moves to attack when hajj asks
for them to wait she emphasizes that
they are unarmed in motions to a slid
being pulled by a horse saying that the
malians do not need to worry about their
companion either since he is a harmless
man who refuses to die earlier on hanj
lured and shot a jaeger a soldier who
came looking for the companion hunter
then returned to the camp where a
severely wounded levi was resting she
surmises that the only reason he
survived his injuries is due to his
ackerman heritage she fears that they
will be unable to stop the jagerists
even if aaron defects from zeke and
wonders if their time has come hanche
was building a sled for levi's
transportation when aaron had used the
founding titan's power to speak to all
of the subjects of ymir levi had woken
from it and immediately demanded to know
where zeke had gone he's bothered that
he did not realize that zeke was
prepared to die and that had made him
careless noticing the sled he asks hanj
about it and comments that they are
unable to stay out of the action despite
their doubts after encountering mcgath
and pig levi says that their interests
are lying they all want to stop zeke
mcgath is cautious but willing to listen
hans theorises that zeke is trying to
win over aaron so he can use the
founding titan though they know the
founding titan is incredibly huge and
seems impossible to beat hunt feels that
it makes it more necessary for them to
work together their evening connie and
falco make camp for the night connie
contemplates how he should feed falco to
his mother to turn her into a human
again feeling conflicted over killing a
child he wonders if sasha would have
understood the next morning they arrive
at rigako and falco reveals that he
overheard connie talking to himself in
the previous night he asks why connie
took him here while pretending that he
did not know who falco was falco asks if
connie is going to try and take revenge
for sasha's death connie tells falco
that what happened with sasha was part
of a military engagement and he knows
that but shows falco his mother anyway
without telling the boy who the titan
used to be he suggests that falco help
him clean the titan's teeth by climbing
up on a support beam before that can
happen though armin and gabby arrive on
horseback gabby shouts that falco has
inherited the jaw tyson and that connie
is trying to feed him to that titan
connie reacts by grabbing falco and
holding the blade to his throat he
starts climbing the ladder to the beam
above his mother pulling falco along
with him as he defends his actions to
armin gabby urges falco to use the power
of the jaw titan to escape but falco is
confused since he doesn't know what
happened to galliard armin thinks on how
he has failed to live up to irwin's
legacy and he begs gabby to forgive
connie he anchors his wives into the
support beam right above connie's mother
intending to sacrifice himself instead
of falco seeing this connie lets go of
the boy and pushes armin out of the way
before he can fall into the mouth of his
mother connie realises that even if his
mother became human again she would have
suffered because she would have become
the colossal titan she told him to
become a great soldier but instead he
almost hurt a child and one of his
friends connie decides that he still
wants to be a soldier his mother would
be proud of so he suggests that he and
armin go save some people meanwhile
mikasa finds louise in the infirmary
wearing her missing scarf louise can no
longer go outside due to the shrapnel
now embedded in her stomach from the
battle but she still believes in the
jaegerst's cause and has no regrets when
she met erin once he told her to throw
the scarf away but she held on to it as
mikasa leaves louise tells her that she
became a soldier because she had admired
her outside flock announces that the
time of the aldian persecution has come
to an end gene appears to have sided
with the jaegerists that make us the
watches from within the crowd citizens
begin celebrating and amen connie falco
and gabby get some food before they
continue their plan to group up with
rainer when they sit down they realize
that annie is sitting right next to them
and scarfing down a pie upon noticing
them annie becomes visibly uncomfortable
and connie is shocked by what a sloppy
eater she actually is later on hatch
came back and noticed that annie was
gone having left a note which said that
she was with her former conrads and
thanked hitch for having spoken to her
for all those years flock and gene take
yelena and anjan kopon to the roof of
the destroyed headquarters and prepare
to execute them flock reveals how
yelena's real objective was to assist
zeke for this euthanization plan and how
onion kopon did not know of this plan
but refused to submit to the aldean
empire onion compound disputes flock's
reasoning for killing him saying that he
had hoped saving aldia would save his
homeland instead of destroying hers he
pleads his case to the gathered crowd
but they are silenced when gene shoots
four times into the ground barely
missing onion copon jean complains about
his aim and as flock asks what he is
doing the kart titan begins plowing
through the crowd seeing the titan gene
pushes flock out of the way before being
swallowed by the cart titan along with
the elena and onion coupon thok orders
the jaegers to follow them and is
surprised to see that mikasa is missing
as well at the bottom of the thought
mikasa and connie react to the four
gunshot signals sent by jing and
continue their operation the two of them
along with annie armon gabby and falco
have a pair of wagons loaded with
weapons and food knowing that the
attention is currently on the other side
of the fort they leave and as they leave
annie notices a figure in an upper
window is watching them after meeting up
with mageth levi and han and the three
who were inside the cart titan's mouth
clean themselves off in a river onion
coppon asks jane when they aligned
themselves with mali and gene replies
that it was last night surprised onyan
kopon asks why he gave up a future with
the jaegerists and jane gives him a
vague reply about how some bones would
never forgive him if he did not when
elena inquires why she was brought to
han reveals that it was a personal
request from mcgarth the team with the
wagon finds reiner in the room where
gabby left him and annie kicks him awake
ryan is surprised to see her again and
starts to panic after seeing his former
friends surrounding him gabby and falco
calm him down saying that they are all
on the same side now connie tells him
that they do not have any time and ryan
asks where they are going with connie
replying that they're going to save the
world and that they need ryder's help to
do so a day before while daydreaming
gene imagines a world where his life as
a soldier is over and here's with his
wife and child but he cannot ignore then
knocking on his window from hanj she
briefs the two of them on levi's prison
condition and how they joined forces
with mageth and peak to stop aaron given
the destruction of the island's military
hajj no longer feels that they can
command gina makassa but hun still wants
their help
she feels that their current team is
powerless without gene or macassar's
assistance or that of the nine titans
mikasa agrees hoping to save aaron from
any additional attacks even if he means
to protect paradise island gene is
skeptical though as even if they stop
erin they will not end the world's
hatred of them that will take decades to
end and aaron would only have the
founding titan for another four years
due to the curse of ymir hanj and jin
debate over the plans and if they could
buy some time by stopping aaron jean
points out that nothing they have tried
so far has worked which is why erin has
decided that it was necessary to wipe
out the rest of the world hunch snaps
refusing to support the solution but
moments later she apologizes and
acknowledges their idealism that led to
aaron's current path she wants to run
away and forget about everything but
they cannot forget their devotion to the
freedom of humanity most of their
comrades had died without knowing any of
the truth of the outside world and they
wonder if any of the fallen soldiers
would be so narrow-minded as to only
wish for freedom for those on the island
hunch believes that they only have one
chance to stop this slaughter and that
is now jen agrees saying that he is
still a member of the survey corps the
following night after the rescue of
elena and onion coupon a group
consisting of survey corps members
malian soldiers and the anti-malian
volunteers gather around a campfire
while hanja's cooking hunt encourages
them to help out instead of staring each
other down while mageth marvels at the
fact that they aren't united at all he
doesn't understand what a survey call
will help him given that they will get a
world of freedom if they let aaron go
hand reminds him that they do not want
complete extinction which mcath
misconstrues is seeing the side of
justice prompting gene to bring up all
the titans mali has sent them over the
years jean says that is why they fought
so hard and mcgath retorts that thanks
to their dedication mali's fears about
paradise has come true hanjin calls out
to end their bickering reminding them
that none of the people present saw
anything that happened two thousand
years ago [__] explains for mega-earth's
benefit that the group of them and their
survey corps have lived in the outside
world for a few months so they cannot go
back to being ignorant island devils and
he asks if that means aaron's friends
are capable of killing him now mikasa
does not believe that killing him is the
only way to stop him but annie is
undeterred she pushes mikasa and armand
for her last resort plan should aaron
not listen to reason but they do not
answer and he believes that they will
end up fighting again if their warriors
try to kill aaron as she doubts mikasa
in particular has ever considered
anything to be more important than aaron
asmikasa prepares to face her and he
flicks out the barb on her ring so that
she can injure herself before they clash
she tells mikasa that she understands
how she feels the only reason she wants
to stop erin is to protect her father if
mikasa can convince erin so much the
better and they should not fight until
it comes down to that in which mikasa
agrees hanji announces that the stew is
ready and lays out the plan as everyone
eats they are going to rely on kiyomi's
flying boat to approach the founding
titan but before that they need to
relocate the founder itself mcgath says
that is why he requested yelena's
capture however yelena is uncooperative
connie is surprised expecting that she
would want to save her homeland but
mcgath and pique reveal that that is not
the case yelena is marlian disillusioned
with her own country she came up with a
story after she met zeke one which would
paint a picture of her saving the world
with a prince yelena is unbothered by
the truth and explains that she does not
see her actions as any different from
the ones that are currently taking place
they also say they are saving the world
and in her eyes they are using it as an
excuse to pretend their hatred for each
other never existed she calls out how
rainer and annie killed numerous
citizens of parodies including former
comrades yelana questions armin's
tactics at the poor in the city and how
someone so sensible could recklessly
destroy the malian naval fleet using the
colossal titan showing everyone the
extent of power that he stole from burt
hold she then talks about how their
survey corps in turn wreaked havoc on
liberio taking few casualties because
they were so effective against the
military and civilians alike after her
silence jane breaks it by telling hanj
that her stew is great and asks for
seconds he expresses gratitude to elena
for airing their grudges so that they
can put them behind them but she does
not let him off easily suggesting that
he ask about marco and he begins to
explain that she was the one who took
off marco's equipment but rainer adds
that she only did so under his orders
marco had overheard reiner ann berthold
speaking and they were afraid of being
found out so they removed his gear and
left him to be eaten by a titan gene
asks if marco had said anything to them
at the end and rhino replies that marco
had said we haven't even tried to talk
about this yet which is the reason why
they have been fighting each other this
entire time
if they talked about it sooner this
bloodshed could have been avoided hans
says that it is not too late to start
though they would have not imagined it
before they are all eating around a fire
now rhino still feels guilty over
marco's death and does not want
forgiveness but is unable to stop
talking about his feelings even though
jane no longer wants to hear about it
after an unrequested story jen gets up
and throttles reiner connie and armin
have to pull him away and he
accidentally kicks gaby when she tries
to protect her cousin the shock of
hitting her gets gene to completely stop
falco runs up asking if she is all right
the gabby turns to jane and tells him
that they wanted to slaughter the people
of parodies so that the world would
accept them and forgive them but now
everyone they care about is going to be
taken away because of it she apologizes
and asks gene and the other survey corps
members to help them stop the rumbling
gene asks to be let go and runs off into
the woods gabby despairs over his
departure but while in the woods gene
holds his head still suffering the next
morning jean lets gaby know that he does
indeed intend to help them and they
leave for the harbor and a pair of
wagons he apologizes to gabby for
kicking her but does not apologize to
rainer who accepts there pick approaches
the group and her cart titan after
having scouted ahead and informs them
that the jaegers have captured the
harbour they must have gone ahead and
used the steam engine train and they are
currently prepared for battle with
soldiers equipped with anti-titan gear
inside of the harbour fox stands behind
a captive kiomi with a pistol in hand
well that officially brings us to the
very end of part one of attack on
titan's war on paradise or warfare
paradise arc and honestly this arc here
is actually like insane some of the the
paneling and the story that is going on
at this point in the story is unreal and
i've enjoyed it probably more than
anything that i've edited on so far
story wise it's just been extremely
enjoyable and i hope you do like the
kind of new style of editing that i've
i've used for this kind of video to get
around what's happened in the past
obviously if you guys want to like
support me and one of my mates as well
then make sure you go down in the
description below and check out his link
and like my patreons and all that kind
of stuff and try and get him to 500 subs
honestly i think he'd he'd kind of love
that and i thought i'd just chuck this
in here at the end of the video because
he's helped me out more than you could
possibly imagine with like starting my
youtube channel and growing it but yeah
honestly like seeing him want to start a
channel now and wanting to grow there
and work on that is you know like
awesome and i want him to do well and i
want to i want to have to like make
content or similar kind of content with
him in the future so you know make sure
you go down to the description and check
his channel out and you know watch a
couple of his videos if you guys are
interested but yeah anyway if you guys
have enjoyed this video and want to keep
up to date with the latest like anime
explained videos for a variety of
different series and want to watch the
second half of this video when it comes
out and probably about two weeks time
from now like first or second weekend of
march then make sure you hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video as it really
helps with pushing my stuff to a bunch
of new amazing people but for now it's
been your professional degenerate
diavolo and i'll see you all in a bit
bye